hey I was going everybody
I guess I'll start the scream off by
saying thank you because we had just
recently passed 50,000 subscribers and
I'm super grateful for that and that's
actually one of the main reasons that I
wanted to do this stream because I have
a bunch of stuff to give away so we
let's see here we'll start oops I'm
sorry can you guys hear me alright okay
okay yeah sorry about that interruption
always having some audio issues again
yeah basically we have a couple
giveaways in this video so that at the
end of the video we'll give away the
free one of a kind t-shirt that we that
I showed you in the last video it's a as
the JavaScript logo and then I also have
a giveaway to everybody on this stream
and that was that's gonna be done with a
angular firebase app that I actually
just put together last night and so
hopefully that everything goes okay
there um but before we really get into
that I just wanted to give you a couple
updates on the things that I'm working
on currently and so for this week later
this week we'll have a tensorflow J s
video which should definitely be really
cool and that should be out maybe
tomorrow or Wednesday at the latest and
then also working on a extension to the
ionic course if you remember we did a
poll about a couple weeks ago when the
ionic course first came out and the top
votes were for a chat feature and for a
file uploading system with the camera so
I think we're gonna try and not bolt
those out in a single feature and do a
chat real-time chat with file uploads
and possibly even geolocation features
in the future as well and I'd say about
that's probably roughly two weeks out
from being added to the existing course
so those are the main things that I'm
working on currently I'm also making
quite a bit of progress on the fire ship
IL project for pro members I'll probably
have like an early preview out on that
in about a month and some more details
all kind of some more details out about
that here in the next few weeks but for
now I'm gonna go ahead and screen share
and I'll show you what I'm giving away
to everybody on the stream currently
well hopefully it depends on how many
people get on this stream but we'll see
so I'm gonna switch over to a screen
share get real quick and so this is what
we're giving away and it's a it's a
die-cut sticker like a pretty good size
good size for your laptop um and it's a
real-time app so there's like 199 of
these remaining I ordered that 200 of
them and I'm gonna take one for myself
and basically what you do is when you
get on this app you can log in with
Google and then there's a little form
for you to fill out here which will just
take your address they'll make sure that
looks correct and then once you're
confirmed it's going to save your
address and Fire store and I'll be able
to export all these all together so I
can format address shipping labels for
everybody and so it is kind of a
time-sensitive thing if you're on this
stream now there's about a hundred and
680 people on now to everybody right now
it's got a chance to get one of these
stickers and I just put the link there
hopefully that old yeah hopefully I'll
give everybody on the stream a chance to
to grab one of these but if you're a pro
member and you miss out on one of these
I've also added a link to the pro
dashboard and if you go on to Angela
firebase.com on the dashboard you'll see
a link under the pro extras for a Google
Form and you can fill one out there and
that will also get you a sticker shipped
out in this in this order and
so I'll give everybody a few minutes to
fill this out and there's actually a few
things with this app that I want to show
you because there's some interesting
patterns that that you want to know if
you're building an app like this because
it's kind of interesting you can see
here we're already at 172 and all of
these addresses are being added to the
firestore database in real time that
we're looking at here which is pretty
cool so yeah hopefully everything goes
well but I mean it looks like firebase
is handling this you know spike in
traffic seamlessly at least on my end
but if you are if you do run into any
problems with the app let me know
because I'm kind of curious to see how
all that works out let's see here so I'm
gonna now switch over to vs code and
this is pretty much just a vanilla
angular app with with firebase installed
everything is in red here because I
don't have the NPM packages installed so
you can kind of ignore that but well
everybody's filling that out I wanted to
show what I think is one of the more
important patterns that you'll see in an
angular firebase app because a lot of
times what happens is you have a user
authenticated and then you have some
additional information about that user
that's based on their user ID so in this
example when you login with Google it's
going to create a user ID then we save a
document and fire store with your
address and that document is your user
ID so you can only save you know request
one sticker per per user let's see yeah
and it looks like these are go pretty
quick there's actually over 200 people
on the screen now so if you don't happen
to get one on this video I'm probably
gonna do this again very soon and then
like I said if you're a pro member
you'll get one anyway so yeah last time
we only had about a hundred a little
over a hundred people on the stream so
it's a little more than I expected
let's see here
okay so getting back to that pattern
after when I want a user and with
firebase using angular fire two I'm
gonna have that user available as an
observable which I'm working
here and then to get their information
from the database we can do something
like this where we take that user and
pipe in the switch map operator and when
you do a switch map you're switching to
a new you're taking one observable and
then switching to a new observable so in
this case we can also get a document in
fire store that has an observable which
we can do by calling collection stickers
with the documents user ID and then
value changes so if you have a component
like like in a real world app you're
normally gonna have an authentication
service you can inject that service in a
component that maybe shows this
confirmed confirmed record from the
database and then you just switch map to
the observable and you'll have a
reactive component that you know always
stays up-to-date in real time so that's
just something to one pattern that
you'll find very useful as you're doing
angularfire
firebase development and let's see here
so there's some more code going on here
it's pretty a pretty straightforward
stuff we just have a reactive form set
up and then a couple of button the event
handlers to log in and log out and the
more there's one more pattern that I
want to show you in the HTML and one
thing that I really like to do is use
the ng-if directive and then you take
your observable and pipe in the async or
use the async pipe and then you set it
as a template variable so like you can
see right here we're doing this on the
main main element in this component so
when we do that we'll have this count
observable available throughout the HTML
so now we can set up like additional
energy of statements that says this says
if the count is less than 200 then we'll
show the sticker form but once the count
goes above 200 that means we're all sold
out of stickers and we'll show a
different template to the user so like
going
back to our component type script that
means we never have to actually
subscribe to anything it all just just
works in the HTML and a huge benefit of
doing that is that the async pipe will
automatically unsubscribe from the
server rules when the components
destroyed so you never have to worry
about memory leaks or anything like that
and you can also improve performance
because if you only use the async pipe
and observables for your presentational
data you can turn off angular's change
detection but it will still update the
changes in the component because the
async pipe knows what to do basically
and what it actually does under the hood
is it marks your data for change
detection so it will run on each new
cycle of change detection so those are
just a couple of cool patterns that I
found you know working with angular
firebase apps let's see I'm gonna go
check on the chat and see everything's
going for everybody oh are you guys okay
looks like some are you getting audio
but some somewhere okay yeah I'm gonna
go ahead and yeah pasted in that's blank
here that's how you get the sticker so
okay cool looks like audio is fine so
sorry about that and yeah and looks like
fire source handling all this data might
you know as far as my on my interior
looks like everything is working as
planned so that's cool and yeah I think
I don't really have any other tips like
as far as that code goes I was going to
put together some additional JavaScript
tips but I kind of just ran out of time
before this stream so there is one more
thing to give away and for this one it's
going to pool
the comments from last week's video
which is the JavaScript pro tips code
this not that so if you so if you
haven't I'm sorry I'm just reading the
comments here I'll try and jump back
here and answer some of these questions
towards the end but for now we'll go
ahead and pick the t-shirt winner from
that from that video all right so
there's going to be about a five-second
delay here and then whoever's name pops
up here from the comments you win that
shirt all right so Navin II I'm not
gonna say the name right but you were at
index 74 of a hundred and fifty comments
there this is a lucky comment and yeah
you're right it was lucky so
congratulations and if you're on our
slack channel the best way to redeem the
shirt is to message me on slack
otherwise I will post a comment on your
original comment and you can send me an
email directly okay yeah someone asked
any advice on how to get involved on
machine learning Kevin Rodriguez and the
I think in my opinion the best way to
learn start learning machine learning is
to compete in data science competitions
on Kaggle if you go to casual comm it's
a it's good website where companies can
put up money to crowdsource their data
science needs um but you as someone who
is learning data science can go on the
side and like actually see what it's
like to work with real-world data and I
used to be really into this and like
achieved a fairly high rank in the
overall community but I haven't had a
whole lot of time to do data science
competitions recently um but it's pretty
cool and if you get good at this you
know the prices go up to a hundred
thousand dollars or even you know above
a million dollars in some cases
see here I'm just gonna jump to the
comments and see if I can grab something
out of here so Kyle asks can you tell us
the difference between angular firebase
and fire [ __ ] there's a couple reasons
that I wanted to kind of rebrand
everything because the name angular
firebase is not well like I said at the
beginning of the video that I originally
started this project with just like
really only expecting to do a few videos
and using the name angular firebase sort
of ties me to those two technologies and
it also sort of kind of like infringes
on their turf a little bit and so I just
want something that's my own brand that
I can you know do for the long term and
then as far as features go and really
like trying to work hard to make the
content experience as optimized as
possible for kind of the intermediate to
advanced developer who's actually
building a software product so I'll
provide some more details about that in
the future but a lot of it centered
around you know keeping content
up-to-date and keeping things really as
efficient and user-friendly as possible
and let's see okay axe last in the
videos we always write code like if
you're oppressing control Z how do you
do that and that's exactly how I do it
is by pressing control Z I just delete
everything in Reverse and then do
control Z I've explained that in a in
episode 100 I think so if you yeah
episode 100 if you check that out you'll
be able to see exactly how I do it and
there
hmm okay it's cool so if anyone's just
like jumping on right now the giveaway
link is right here in the chat go on
their register your address and then I'm
going to export all of these and mail
them out and let's say give us give us
your PC spec so actually the PC I'm
using I built myself it's got an Intel
i7 processor it's a couple years old now
so I'm actually thinking about building
another PC and I'll probably do that in
near future
especially now because the new NVIDIA
GPUs just came out recently so I'll
probably just build a new computer from
scratch and with the new with the new
GPU and this one has a GTX 1080 which is
a pretty popular one which is now the
previous generation and see me at any
conference soon yes well yes no so I
have a newborn which is made it pretty
difficult to travel and there's a GD
Google developer expert summit that's
coming up here in November that'll be at
which will be in the Bay Area so if
you're if you're around the Bay Area we
could grab a beer or something and then
traveling to big conferences I'll
probably have to put off until probably
until next year just because it's yeah
it's tough to travel with the baby and
let's see why don't you start doing a
bunch of flutter tutorials that's a good
question I I've thought about doing
flutter flutter tutorials and I've done
quite a bit of messing around with water
but still I don't know I still wouldn't
call myself an expert at building mobile
apps with water but that's definitely
something on my mind that I might do in
the future because it's relatively easy
to jump to especially if you know
typescript like darts a pretty intuitive
programming language that has really
good tooling and everything
[Music]
and we'll see give me one second here
I'm going to switch over it looks like
yeah there's 30 31 stickers remaining so
yeah make sure to get your address in
there
all right so I'm probably gonna go ahead
and wrap up the livestream pretty soon
here and I'm gonna try and do these live
streams maybe hopefully once a week but
maybe every two weeks or so and I'll try
and like collect questions beforehand
just so we can be a little more prepared
I mostly just wanted to do the giveaway
in this video so if we went everybody
could grab that and then we have our
winner here for the t-shirt so make sure
that I get in touch with me yeah I need
okay so sir off says I need your
autograph when I send out these stickers
I'm also going to send out a little
business card and I'm gonna do either an
autograph where a little note for each
one of them as well so just FYI I'm
doing that on top of just the sticker
are you self-employed or do you work
from a company and do this on the side
and so I'm self-employed I've actually
been doing web development consulting
for over five years independently now
and since I started this last year it's
slowly become like the main priority of
what I work on I still have a couple of
consulting clients but primarily I want
to focus on building the fire ship
product which will be sort of the
successor to angular firebase and really
just trying to make the best possible
developer education and consulting
content that exists in the world that's
really my mission more than anything
do i do podcast work no not really I've
been on a couple of podcasts but yeah
I'm definitely open to it if you have a
podcast feel free to invite me and I'll
you know I'll try and make it on
alright cool well again thanks everybody
and thanks for 50 thousand subscribers
like I said we'll do this again here in
the near future and then I'll leave that
16 Romanian stickers open so if you're
coming in after the live stream is over
there's still a small chance to get one
and again if you're a pro member you can
grab one from the pro dashboard alright
well thanks a lot everybody and I'll see
you soon
[Music]
[Music]